so my audience has gone from as we know
it's uh recently it went to like like 60
mail um is mine it's all the jojo's [ __ ]
you've been doing
jojo i think also there was a good
amount of time where
i think because of my thumbnails because
the tops i was covering youtube just
didn't recommend me to guys
yeah and now it suddenly started being
like oh wait guys can watch this guy too
yeah and so i started getting a massive
influx of guy viewers that i never had
before
right right and i stopped doing as much
yowie stuff and slow down on that but
i mean it's still like nearly it's like
it depends on the month it's like
depending on the videos i make yeah it's
about 50 50 now which is nice and it's
slowed down a lot
uh but there's up some downsides right
like it was mainly like i i know that i
spoke about like mainly like it was like
girls coming up to me but
dude guys hit on me just as much uh
really yeah yeah i've had that which is
flattering because there was like one
dude
who's in my instagram message request
matt was [ __ ] ripped as [ __ ] and i
was like wow
i'm i'm very flattered this man had like
the body of a greek statue and this man
thought i was worthy of being hit on i
was very i was very fast oh man jealous
yeah
right right i was like damn damn but uh
yeah i mean it's it's it's it's whatever
it's [ __ ] youtube
yeah i mean what i can take about this
is that if there is going to be an
avenue not necessarily to be hit on but
for someone to get into contact with
contact with you because half
i would say half of these were just you
know the fan interactions or people
trying to get in contact with you if
there's an avenue
people are going to find a way and i've
definitely felt that as a youtuber as
well
yeah i mean you can hit on me it's very
flattering i don't care do you don't
have to stop doing it just don't be
creepy
just do it in a sophisticated way yeah
man you do it slick i'll be like thank
you for the ego boost i'm going to go
away feeling great then yeah
yeah who doesn't dude when you get hit
on you're like damn i'm a 10.
and then you go back to hotel room a
whole bag of flaming hot cheetos and
realize you're truly a five yeah
and also the on the opposite end any
uh taking this advice for any like young
budding youtubers out there
like tread carefully with fans hitting
on you don't [ __ ] your fans man it it
never works out
you know it might work out one tenth of
the time but there's the problem is is
that but are you willing to take the
risk
yeah i mean you have to be really
careful and i think the biggest problem
is that whenever whenever you're like a
youtuber starting out especially when
you're a small youtuber i feel like
this is more a message to small
youtubers
um who don't have the experience or
don't think they're gonna get big
because you don't [ __ ] know if you're
gonna get big
right but you should treat you should
treat the fans or you should treat your
audience
no matter how big you are exactly the
same and it's it's stay grounded yeah
i mean i'm sure there's cringy messages
out there of me hitting on someone at 19
that would just embarrass me but it's
again i'm 19 you know just [ __ ] yeah
but like you're you're like
it wasn't like hit on fans of me like
shimmy nudes you know what i mean
like just me being an average 19 year
old yeah exactly like when you're
younger like you don't you don't really
have like the senses to know what
exactly is cringe you're not also when
you're younger you're just hoarding as
[ __ ] yeah exactly
and and you think you can get away with
you know being horny
and you grow up and you realize man i
did a lot of stupid [ __ ]
yeah young dumb and full of calm that's
as they say
lovely joey words to live by yeah but i
mean it's
it's like because there's some people
you know there's a lot of youtubers out
there
very very openly happy to admit that
they date fans they're like well
you know normal famous celebrities get
to [ __ ] their fans and no one bets an
eye
and it's like well i mean yeah that
double standard is like
the reason why i uh this is the way i
interpret it and why that's the case
that normal celebrities
they don't bank on the fact of
relatability they don't bank on the fact
of being they're like people above the
club
well their whole like every like pop
star is supposed to be like a character
like an absurd kind of
not real person yeah right they never
pretend to be your friend
they never like pretend to give a [ __ ]
about you yeah and if you have sex with
them they'll probably don't give a [ __ ]
about it right maybe maybe right it's
just a joke but
i mean if you do it with an influencer
right or crush word or a youtuber right
i i i hate that
i guess it's almost kind of a betrayal
of what you built up which is like
a lot of the people who watch us right i
guess i don't know if you guys know like
you guys feel this way like there's a
you form like a bit of a bond right
where you like you respect the creator
and
you look up to them and you enjoy their
stuff and you feel a lot closer to a
youtuber than you would say
yeah and so it's that it's being taken
advantage right it's because most
youtubers are more
i guess grounded right you feel more
real so when you do watch them you're
just like oh
this is an actual person i'm watching
yeah like like i would say
to be like the right way to go about it
is if you're if you're going to get
involved with your fans
that you just one of the biggest things
is you don't do it straight away
like you need to treat as a friend start
as a friend treat them like a human
being
get the get to know each other first
like any normal [ __ ] relationship
you have to like immediately like break
down or disassemble any like power
dynamic in play
that's like fat yeah and and like when
you put yourself on equal footing yeah
and with stuff like one night stands or
something that's
that gets so messy and there's no way to
like differentiate is there a power
dynamic there is
is the person is the person gonna do
this and then you know regret it
afterwards and just
it it's too messy to be able to justify
i feel um and if there is a right way to
go about it and
there's nothing about it but like most
of the time it's like you know
it's like do you want to defuse a bomb
like you if you know how to
yeah you want to do that yeah go ahead
there's a right way to do it but it's
not worth it
yeah but like is it worth is it like is
it worth the risk
literally blowing yourself up in terms
of career like is it worth it or you
could just
i don't know be do what everyone else
[ __ ] does
date normally and i feel like a lot of
smaller youtubers don't
like they they don't really think about
this because they think i've got nothing
to lose so i'm just gonna do this right
now while
while i can because you grew up in a
culture where yeah you do see
you know celebrities and like groupies
it's like sleeping with
you know music artists and everything
like that and you think man
that sounds like an awesome lifestyle i
kind of like that lifestyle so when they
get like a
smidgen of that they think i got to take
advantage of this
while i still can rock and roll
lifestyle works if you're in that field
the rock and roll lifestyle is not the
youtuber lifestyle it's two completely
different things i find
yeah it's it's tough it's so tough and
it's like is it just like it's not even
worth like getting into yeah
right because i feel like to get
involved in this is it's you are
literally navigating a minefield
oh yeah 100 it's like if you really want
to do it you can do it yeah
but the reason why i think most
youtubers will say don't [ __ ] your fans
is because
it's just like it's so much it's so much
risk you're taking on for no reason
like it and and to me it's like do you
really want someone who wants to be with
you
for your videos is that like why is that
attractive like
they're looking at you only for the
crowd right because to me it's a
competitive mindset
to me that's like a massive turn off if
they're only with me
because of my content then that's like
the same thing if you're only my friend
for my content then you i'm saying you
can't be my friend
because that's that's not how i would
see a friend yeah the same way that's
how i wouldn't see like a possible
partner or anything like that's like
saying like also if i change my content
then you're suddenly not my friend
yeah yeah i there is no bigger turn on
right than meeting someone
who just likes you for you yeah like
what why why i'm sitting there i'm
thinking like
how the [ __ ] am i supposed to be into
this and then like get my dick hard
when i'm all i'm thinking about you're
thinking is like what's the next upload
going to be
like [ __ ] that no i i want someone who
like speaks to me knows nothing about
youtube and he's like holy [ __ ]
like this guy's [ __ ] cool i like him
he's so nice you want people to see you
as connor not cedaw
yeah yeah which obviously i made a bit
difficult for myself obviously but all
right
i can still still still still go about
it yeah of course you know you don't
want to be with a girl
be in bed and be like yo if you enjoyed
that session hit the subscribe button
click the like button
if we get to 5 000 likes i'll do round
two
want a youtube video of someone trying
to do that
oh my god yeah i feel like oh my god
yeah there's
so many [ __ ] douche tubers out there
who do [ __ ]
i'm sure there's youtubers out there who
just admit every single [ __ ] day like
yeah i [ __ ] my fans so well and like
i mean screw them but if you want to
have like you know something if you want
to be respected by the community
yeah if you want to be seen as like a
role model don't know what that is
yeah i mean like douche tubers i feel
just exist on a different plane of
existence where
i don't know how they function or you
know
i i just i just want youtubers to have a
better rap right like
not all of us are [ __ ] psychopath
uh degree chasing
a lot of us are horny [ __ ] and
that's that's just the
that's just human nature that is the
only but we we do it the right way yeah
yeah yeah yeah
father knows breasts on blu-ray you know
we are three horny guys but at least
we're horny on maine and uh
we keep to being horny on maine and uh
that's pretty much it pretty much